Zach woods that guy is experiencing this
huge surge in popularity online not just
popularity popularity with the ladies
yes yeah and I you know not that he's a
he's a we have a picture here of Zach
woods he's a fine-looking fella yeah
yeah I think there's a bit of a tie in
cuz you know yeah III think it's yeah I
think it's a total catch but I think
something with Jared on Silicon Valley
where he's this sort of very sensitive
guy and I think as soon as Russ Hanneman
said you know this guy f's
this guy of his character yet he yeah
you mean he met Russ Hanneman the
loudest braggadocio guy in the show he
meets everybody and then he sees
journeys like hey this guy I think since
then and because zach has no social
media whatsoever he's this elusive
little fairy that when he's gonna love
this by the way yeah yeah anytime I put
a picture of him on my Instagram it
there the likes go through the roof yes
on there's a do we have that picture of
the account I think we do there's an
Instagram account yeah account called
hot dudes reading and guess what I'll
never be on there because I think
readings for you know losers but uh but
it says hashtag freak me I mean that's
forward yeah yeah is he enjoying the
success do you think oh yeah he's single
and ready to mingle man know what's
happening I can't gauge the audience's
response I well they don't like me no no
that's totally wrong I think it's the
suit I've lost you guys from the know
you committed no that's not true you
came out and you did what most people do
when they're trying to win over crab
which is that you said I hate children
like a giant ego agreement no no you're
doing great yeah you're doing great
you